- Welcome back everybody.
Before we go, I have
one more inspiring story
from social media to share.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
June is National Cancer Survivor Month.
Nearly 17 million people in
the US are cancer survivors.
That includes anyone currently
battling the disease as well.
So, if you're fighting cancer
right now, you are a survivor.
I want to introduce you
to one cancer survivor
with an inspiring message for everybody.
Say hello to Crisann
who watches on NBC 4 Los Angeles.
So Crisann, you are welcome
to the show first of all, hello.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you.
- You are battling cancer as we speak.
Is this right?
- Yeah, I was diagnosed
about two years ago
and I've been fighting
it every day since then.
I'm a single mom, so it's
a little bit tough for me
because I have stage four
metastatic breast cancer.
But I go in every three
weeks and I get my treatment
and I think as every survivor knows,
you just keep moving forward.
You don't stop, you keep moving.
And I think I can speak for all of us
when I say that we're so grateful
to be having continued treatment
and for all of the doctors and the nurses
and the hospital staff that
help us get through this.
You know, cancer changes
you in every possible way.
It makes you know beyond
a shadow of a doubt
what's really important in life.
And for me, that's the
amazing network of support
that I have that helps me get through it
and makes me grateful for
every day that I'm given.
- Wow.
Well, you discovered something
on this journey that's helped.
What is that?
- I think really just to enjoy
your life every day, right?
Right now, right this very minute.
For me, I enjoy "Ted Lasso."
- Love "Ted Lasso."
- The show makes me so happy.
It fills me with such joy.
I mean, it's really
ultimately about kindness.
And cancer teaches you about kindness.
I even heard from some
of the cast members.
They sent me get well
and encouragement videos,
and were just completely amazing.
But what I think I wanna say
and remind everybody is that
cancer touches all of us.
You know?
So, lend your support
and celebrate the people
who are fighting this battle right now.
Whether it's somebody you know with cancer
or a healthcare professional
that is helping somebody battle cancer.
Give them your celebration and support.
I mean, we're gonna win this fight,
but we would love your support too.
- Absolutely.
Thank you so much, Crisann,
for sharing your story with us.
I'm a single mama as well.
I can't imagine all that's
on your plate right now.
So, God bless you.
You're in my prayers.
You're in my thoughts.
You're in all of our thoughts.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
(audience clapping)
- [Crisann] Thank you.
- And that's not all Crisann.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience clapping)
- Oh, thank you.
That's so great.
I really appreciate that.
- Absolutely.
And I have to say I love
your rock and roll hair.
I just couldn't let you leave
without me talking about your pink hair.
It's so cute.
- Thank you.
- So, thank you so much Crisann.
and thank you to all of
our guests this hour:
Eva Longoria, Annie
Gonzalez, Jesse Garcia,
and Colton Dixon.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.